So let's try a few examples.
So I'll create a dictionary.
We're using the squiggly brackets.
And some keyboards that's the shift
on the square bracket key.
It may be somewhere
else on your keyboard.
And we're going to use
the squiggly bracket,
list our elements in the dictionary.
So each element of the dictionary
is a key value pair.
And the entries in the dictionary
will be the elements and their atomic
numbers, so we have the string
hydrogen with its atomic number 1.
And we have carbon with number 6.
So we've created the dictionary,
and what we see when we print it out
is the elements of the dictionary.
Now one thing you might notice is,
they're not in the same order
that we put them there.
If you think about what we did with
hash tables, this isn't so surprising.
When we put elements in hash tables,
well where they end
in the hash table depends on the key and
the hash function.
It's not necessarily in
the order that we put them in.
And with the dictionary, because
it's implemented like a hash table,
we see the same thing.
Unlike a list,
where the elements are ordered, with a
dictionary there's no order to elements.
So when we print it out,
they might appear in a different order
from the order that we put them in.
We can use the indexing to
lookup one of the elements.
So now when we lookup the value
associated with hydrogen, we get one.
And if we lookup the value
associated with carbon, we get six.
What do you think's going to happen
if we look up a value that's not in
the dictionary?
So now we're looking up the value
associated with lithium.
And what we get is an error.
It's called the KeyError.
KeyError, it says that element
is not in the dictionary.
This is different from how we define
lookup for our hash table, right?
We defined our lookup to return none,
when the element is not there.
The way the built in
dictionary type works,
is it gives us an error
when it's not there.
If we don't want to
get errors like that,
we can use the in, to see if
an element's in the dictionary.
So the in,
behaves similarly to in did for lists.
We can say lithium in elements.
That will evaluate to true, if the key
is in the dictionary, false otherwise.
So now, hit a value it's to false.
So I said that dictionaries were
mutable, so we can add new elements.
And the way to add an element,
is just to use an assignment.
So we'll add lithium, giving it value 3.
Note that it was an error, when we
used an element like this as a lookup.
When it's on the left side of
an assignment, well that's an update.
So that corresponds to
the hash table update.
Where lithium is the key and
3 is the value.
We can add another element.
Let's add another element.
We'll add nitrogen.
And now when we look up nitrogen, we get
the value that we assigned to nitrogen,
which is 8.
Turns out that 8 is not
actually the correct value.
That the atomic number for
nitrogen should be seven.
So we can modify that value,
using another assignment.
That's again the same as
our hash table update.
It won't create a new key value because
the key nitrogen is already there.
But it will update the value, so
now the value associated
with nitrogen will be 7.
So we can see the first print,
the value is 8.
The second print, the value is now 7.